es ist ein Ort den kaum jemand kennt
wenig beachtet und doch notwendig
ungeliebt und doch genutzt
die Bahnhofsmission Frankfurt ein Raum
für die die keinen anderen Ort haben
das erleben wir sehr oft dass Menschen
die hungrig sind und vielleicht auch
nicht geschlafen oder wenig geschlafen
haben die vielleicht auch teilweise von
Drogen konsumieren und vielleicht auch
entzügig sind zu uns mit ja sehr
geringer Toleranz ich bin in schwieriger
Mensch und hier kann man sprechen mit
anderen Menschen zusammen sein ich hatte
Streit gehabt mit meiner Frau jetzt
stehe draußen rausgeschmissen
alles zuständig und es kommen täglich
auch immer neue Aufgaben auf uns zu wo
ich sage wusste ich nicht dass wir
zuständig sind wir machen es trotzdem
und sie machen es jeden Tag egal ob
Werktag oder Feiertag Sommer oder Winter
morgens punkt sieben öffnet sich die Tür
zur Bahnhofsmission Frankfurt und dann
fehlen dieser Tage ist auch Anja Wienand
um diese Uhrzeit schon da gleichzeitig
Chefin und Mädchen für alles
die Bahnhofsmission hier in Frankfurt
ist eine ganz wichtige Anlaufstelle für
alle Menschen die
in am Bahnhof im Bahnhofsviertel in Not
geraten und deshalb ist es so wichtig
dass wir 24 Stunden rund um die Uhr an
365 Tagen für diese Menschen da sind wir
bewerten nicht wie sie in ihre Notlage
geraten sind sondern wir sind jeden Tag
da und versuchen sie in ihren Nöten
wahrzunehmen sie zu begleiten und
vielleicht einen guten Weg aus der
Problematik zu finden
die Menschen in Not es sind Frauen und
Männer Gesunde und Kranke gestrandet für
einen Tag oder Besucher seit Jahren
manche drogenabhängig andere Altarm
krank oder allein sie alle kommen für
einen heißen Kaffee und eine Kleinigkeit
zu essen manche nur Minuten andere
Stunden
und Duschen oder was ist denn
was machen
wenn sie Kaffee trinken
bisher Unterhaltung und das heißt sie
schlafen auf der Straße und morgens
kommen sie jetzt zum Frühstück und ab
und zu mal zum Duschen
normal schon ja also eigentlich auf der
Straße und ja
und ich gebe
und sie haben auch keine sie haben keine
andere Anlaufstelle oder sie wenn man
Hohenheim wo sie mal sein könnten nur so
wo sie sagen na da
versuche ich da unterzukommen sowas
gibt's für sie nicht
gibt's schon aber
hat bis jetzt nicht geklappt
und dann ich
Geld keine gut Geld ja sie haben kein
Geld ja
sie haben auch ich bin arbeite keine ich
bin krank ein bisschen
Leute ich bringe sprechen alleine und so
ja sie sprechen so für sich immer mit
sich selbst ja
sprechen alleine und dann ein bisschen
und sie sind auch ganz alleine sie haben
auch keine Familie Jugendamt
keine Unterkunft niemand der sich
kümmert die Schwierigkeiten sind so
vielfältig wie die Menschen also muss
auch jede Hilfe anders sein mal ist es
ein Anruf beim Sozialamt mal Kleidung
wenn das Geld nicht reicht
ich weiß nicht ob das zu vielleicht zu
eng keine Jacke ich habe also nur das
wir haben nichts anderes aber ich kann
Ihnen eine Adresse geben wo sie noch
andere wo sie mehr Kleider bekommen
da sind schon manche Schicksale dabei
also da denkt man mit den eigenen
Alltagssorgen das ist ein Witz ja und
man sieht auch auf die tapfer die Leute
sind
tapfer aber oft auch hilflos unbedarft
oder überfordert die Geschichten die
Anja Wienand hört ähneln einander immer
wieder die Beziehung gescheitert das
Geld verbraucht die Papiere verloren
immer brauchte Hilfe immer finden Sie
eine Lösung auch diesmal das handelt
sich um einen Herrn der nach Deutschland
kam weil im Arbeit versprochen wurde kam
ursprünglich aus Bulgarien es hat jemand
nicht geklappt mit der Arbeit auch nicht
mit der Bezahlung und deswegen möchte
ich natürlich wieder zurück nach Hause
zu seiner Familie und für diese Menschen
buchen wir auch auf die Reise zurück wir
Fragen schon viel nach ob das alles Sinn
ergibt was uns erzählt wird es wird auch
geschaut ob schon eine Karte ausgestellt
wurde also wenn innerhalb von ein paar
Monaten das zweimal passiert dann gibt's
das nicht noch mal also es gibt nur eine
Karte in einem Jahr sozusagen für andere
ist die Hilfe viel schwieriger zu
organisieren das Problem Drogen Heroin
gibt es in Frankfurt schon immer
inzwischen hat auch Greg die Straßen
erobert Frankfurt ist für gerade für
junge Leute so ein ganz interessantes
Pflaster und viele kommen hier einmal
und finden den Weg nicht mehr zurück
weil Sie hier den ersten Kontakt mit
Drogen haben und das hat auf der großes
Ausmaß leider und die Konsequenz die
Arbeit der Bahnhofsmission wird immer
schwieriger wir merken natürlich auch
unsere Konsumenten wenn die enzügig
werden ich weiß wie sie sich verhalten
und dann fällt manchmal auf dass sie
sich wenn sie entzückend
verhalten dass sie eventuell aggressive
Auftreten und es ist
immer mal wieder der Fall dass wenn wir
das merken dass man dann etwas Zeit
verzögert oft auch eine
drogenmarnmeldung bekommt das schlechter
Stoff unterwegs ist aber es gibt
glücklicherweise auch die eher einfachen
Aufgaben wie zum Beispiel Betreuung und
Begleitung von Reisenden es kann jeder
es kostet nichts ja
nehmen wir gerne ja
einfach anrufen entweder bei der Bahn
oder bei uns direkt wir arbeiten ja mit
der Bahn zusammen und
kein Problem machen wir gerne und
tatsächlich sind es ganz junge oder ganz
alte Reisende oder Menschen mit
Sehbehinderung die den Abholservice am
häufigsten in Anspruch nehmen das klappt
ja Service abholen Dienst im Berlin
werde ich auch wieder abgeholt also ich
bin sehr zufrieden wir kümmern uns
grundsätzlich wirklich um alle wir
kümmern uns auch um alleinreisende
Kinder also wir kümmern uns um alle wenn
wir eine Anfrage gestellt bekommen wir
lehnen grundsätzlich erstmal gar nicht
sein in der Bahnhofsmission herrscht
derweil der ganz normale Andrang viele
stehen an für Essen andere warten bis
die Dusche frei ist die meisten sind
Stammgäste
man kann sich hier also
[Musik]
der Sachen besorgen die man nicht
bekommt oder die man nicht hat
vielleicht auch nicht finanzieren
finanzieren kann oder also man in eine
Bereich ist wo man auch braucht ja seine
Frau braucht
Männer Frauen für alle gelten die
gleichen Regeln alle bekommen die
gleiche Zeit und alle werden gleich
versorgt der größte Teil kommt von der
Straße weil der größte Teil hat auch
immer noch einen anderen Wunsch nämlich
Unterwäsche oder Socken oder andere
Kleidungsstücke die wir eben dann wenn
wir welche haben mitgeben können ein
Zimmer weiter
Wundversorgung eine alte ungepflegte
Verletzung ein Pflaster und ein paar
gute Worte
die kleine Versorgung oftmals das ist
einfach ein Pflaster für die Seele viele
Menschen die bei uns zu Gast sind die
haben keine Krankenversicherung mehr
weil sie aus dem System rausgefallen
sind es gibt zwar hier in Frankfurt auch
stellen die Menschen gut behandeln auch
wenn sie nicht krankenversichert sind
aber bei so kleinen Versorgungen da sind
wir immer wieder anders und zu allem
kommt seit Februar 2022 auch noch der
Krieg in der Ukraine er hat zahlreiche
neue Menschen und zahlreiche neue
Aufgaben gebracht
Caritas und Diakonie die die
Bahnhofsmission gemeinsam tragen
finanzieren auch diese Kosten
wir haben bis zum heutigen Tag
262.000 Menschen hier bei uns in der
Bahnhofsmission gehabt das heißt
manchmal innerhalb von 24 Stunden
2000 Menschen
die wir versorgt haben weitergeleitet
haben
vermittelt haben Fahrkarten ausgestellt
haben und die ganz normalen Aufgaben
gehen ja auch weiter viele Menschen
wollen Hilfe nicht alle aber kennen und
akzeptieren die Regeln
fallen gelassen wird dennoch keiner
ich brauche eine Frühstücksplatz für
meine Klamotte Dusche und sowas weil ich
rechne in Frankfurt lebe natürlich tun
wir hier auch keine ja keine aggressives
Verhalten dass wir ja auch manchmal
Hausverbote für eine gewissen Zeitraum
aussprechen aber wir versuchen natürlich
schon auf der Person zu helfen die Welt
draußen rau und gefährlich auch für
Männer vor allem aber für Frauen ihren
Körper zu verkaufen ist eine der
Möglichkeiten das Überleben zu sichern
und die Bahnhofsmission ist der Raum der
in Ruhe und Sicherheit gibt wenigstens
für ein paar Stunden
bei den Frauen sind halt die Schicksale
schlimmer wie sie an Geld rankommen um
irgendwie zu überleben also wir reden
genau deswegen möchten wir den
Schutzraum bieten dass sie hier ihre
Ruhe haben vor allem von Männern sage
ich mal ihre Ruhe haben und sich hier
wohlfühlen können ohne irgendwie
angegriffen zu werden oder sexuellen
Übergriffe zu erfahren von daher ist es
sehr wichtig dass wir das auch getrennt
halten reden die Frauen oder wollen die
nicht reden wollen die meistens eher
nicht sehr zurückhaltend auch sprechen
nicht gerne darüber
ja kann man auch verstehen ne das sind
Themen von Vergewaltigung bis
eingesperrt seinen Wohnungen
missbraucht werden sind schon sehr harte
Themen teilweise was die Frauen hier
durchmachen müssen
die Bahnhofsmission sie steht für Essen
Trinken Sauberkeit und Ruhe
getragen von Menschen ohne Vorurteile
und Berührungsängste aber mit Herz und
Geduld
ich komme jeden Tag sehr gerne auf die
Arbeit und auch alle Menschen die hier
arbeiten das ganze Team macht es mit
Begeisterung sonst würde das nicht so
funktionieren und in den bunten Sträußen
die ein nahegelegener Blumenladen einmal
in der Woche schickt steckt eine ganz
ähnliche Botschaft sie sagen den
Menschen ihr seid es wert diesen Raum zu
schmücken diesen Ort den kaum jemand
kennt